good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the uh afternoon session of talk two for
pi data
global
uh we have today with us myra of ben
itzak i'm sure i'm mispronouncing that
so apologies
my rav
she is a senior data scientist based in
tel aviv
uh and for the last five years she has
done some
varied analyses as part of her mscs and
as well as her side projects and work
and today she's going to be discussing
storytelling with data
uh taking us into some eda some
narratives about data so go ahead myra
hey everyone thanks for joining into my
talk and thanks for your patience
through the technical difficulties
my name is miraf and today i will
discuss
storytelling with data
so quick hello before we deep dive into
the topic so hi my name is mira i'm a
data scientist been in the past five
years i have a master's degree in
bioinformatics in my spare time i
sometimes write blog posts about data
related topics which you can find on
medium and fun fact i'm also a
contributor on shutterstock and getty
and you can find some of my photography
there if you're curious
so
in this talk i want to share with you
insights and tips
for successful
exploratory data analysis but before we
dive into that let's talk for a second
about how i got into the business of
storytelling with data
so a few years ago in my first position
i felt that my visualization skills in
python were not as sharp as i liked them
to be
and i also felt that my exploratory
analysis skills were a bit weak so i
decided to start this side project where
i will find a data set dig into it
visualize it with sibon and metaport lib
and that way i could exercise
exploratory data analysis and also get
acquainted with those libraries
so i plan that the outcome of this
project will be only a jupiter notebook
on my github which i can later show in
interviews to possible
employees employers
but eventually this project became a
successful blog post on medium and also
a talk in pi data global which is today
and
there will be another talk about this
where i will present my analysis uh
results in pi ladies london next month
then obviously you're invited
so just a small word about the data set
i analyzed so um my data set was taken
from the um open data which is a source
i highly recommend
and
it had two tables one for countries and
one for continents where each table had
three columns country year and the
percentage of female in parliament
in the given year in the given country
so let's say my little anecdote inspired
you to start a similar project where do
you start so the first thing you should
do is find a data set and i suggest you
choose one properly and take into
consideration several factors so the
first one would be
time
so the more time you have to dedicate to
this project the more complex the data
set you choose could be and the opposite
uh the second thing is what tasks do you
like to perform on this data set would
you like this to be
a diet or wrangling
exercise you want to do visualizations
like i did so if you want to do only
visualizations and analysis then i
suggest you take
a pretty much well organized data set in
advance which is what i did if you want
to do wrangling then you should
like take one that has several tables
etc
the third factor is which methods do you
like to apply on it
would you like to do
pandas do you like to do
graph algorithms with your data so if
you want to do graph algorithms i
suggest you choose a data set that is
already in the format of a graph or that
can be easily turned into one
if you want to do
other things then you should choose the
data set accordingly and last but not
least is interest and you can know if
the data set is interesting you if you
have lots of questions when you look at
it
if you found a data set that is suitable
according to all factors except for
interest i suggest you keep looking
because it will bore you and you will
probably ditch the product or that it
just won't be as fun as it could be if
you choose one that is
perfect in all aspects
second is i suggest you pre-process so
even if you want to spend a minimal
portion of your time on organizing the
data i suggest you don't skip this part
so
in my case i was interested in the
temporal patterns of female
representation in parliaments worldwide
um so the first thing i did was convert
my data to a time series format as you
can see in this slide
which made it very easy for me to
not only look at the patterns but also
deep dive into specific years see the
difference between um decades etc
um other options for rearranging could
be
converting the data to graph format
aggregate meld with other data sources
etc use your imagination and have fun
so now that we have the data set and we
have it organized we want to dive in and
i think that exploratory data analysis
should be approached with a
brainstorming attitude which means that
no idea is stupid and every idea is
worth looking into now obviously i don't
suggest you polish every idea to you
know to the maximum but
if you have an idea try it out and see
if it's an interesting lead if not you
can ditch it
so
my suggestions to you are
try out ideas instead of negating them
in advance
play with different ways to analyze and
explore
so this will include
playing with different types of
visualizations
so sometimes when you visualize even if
you visualize the same thing like the
same data in different ways then it
sometimes sheds light on different
aspects of the data and tells you
different things so i do suggest you try
out different types of visualizations
and again don't negate the defense an
idea you have
and also try playing with different
methods to analyze so this could be
descriptive statistics and basic
histograms and line plots and it could
be advanced methods we know as data
scientists such as clustering graph
analysis and stuff like that
if i could summarize the slide in a few
words it would be make this exercise
your playground and just have fun and
try things
now a really important thing to do that
is sometimes overlooked is
put some effort in making things pretty
so here i put two figures of the same
data plotted but on in the same way like
it's both line plots it met blue clear
but on the left side it's the result i
got after just plotting with the default
settings of my prelim and on the right
side
is what i got after a tuning in and
playing with the size and like digging
into the documentation of the package so
i learned that you could play with um
the colors and the
um
you know make the line bolder and i also
played with the font size and type and i
also added the grid in the background
which is nice and last thing i plotted
the legend so that like i played with
the
figure
size in a way that the legend does not
come above asia
as it does on the left side so it didn't
take me too much time it did teach me a
lot and i think it's made a really good
impact on my figure like it made it far
more appealing and informative so i
suggest you do that too
um
so this is pretty much like i said
before but i suggest you also explore
new ways to visualize so the story
behind this figure is that i
clustered subcontinents to learn more
about patterns of representation but i
didn't know how to present the results
of this analysis visually now i had the
same issue in my master's degree as well
i often did clustering on bacterial data
sets
and i never knew how to visualize the
output so i decided to use this
opportunity and figure out a solution to
this problem once and for all
and after looking at images of
clustering results on google i stumbled
upon this package called networkx and
eventually i put my results to a graph
format where the continents are the
source and the cluster number is a
target and then i was able to do this
nice visualizer visualization you see
here
now this little adventure gave me two
things one
it
brought me a way to visualize clustering
results finally and it brought to my
awareness that idea that graphs can be
used for data science which i wasn't
familiar with till that point
so
again exploratory data now this is all
about exploring and you should not only
explore your data but also explore new
methods packages ways to use existing
packages uh new ways to visualize skies
limit
okay so this one is half a dip and half
request um
numbers can get you to some point
but for a complete story you have to
also work with text and qualitative
facts and i'll give some examples so in
this figure i plotted um on the left the
countries with highest representation
and on the right the countries with
lowest representation of female in
parliaments
in 2019 in percentage
now
um
one important thing to notice in this
example
is uh draw attention to the numbers so
if you look at the left side then the x
is
the x axis values are from 0 to 60 and
on the right side is from 0 to seven
which could be confusing due to the size
of the
you know bars but it's really important
to notice and this can be highlighted
through text
also
on the left side you can see
that wanda cuba and bolivia
are the top three in representation but
they're not only top three they're also
the only countries in the world
with majority of women in their
parliaments
and
on the right side interesting things to
say is that
um in yemen there is over zero percent
but less than one percent which is
i think is interesting
now
so the first thing you should do is draw
attention to the numbers and then you
should ask what can we learn from those
numbers and i suggest you think about
questions these numbers evoke so for
example in my analysis i was interested
to know
how did juan de cuba in bolivia reach
such high representation
and also what can we learn from them if
we want to replicate the success in
other places
and on the right side
why is there such slow representation in
tuvalu and kribati and also um
what do we think about yemen having more
than zero percent but less than one
so
this can invoke a really interesting
discussion on whether it should be
a minimal
percentage of seats
taken aside for women
um if we want them to be able to also do
things like what is it like to be such a
minority in such a massive parliament is
it effective is it worthwhile um et
cetera
a last tip i will cry out for you is
please don't keep things to yourself so
the first thing i suggest you do when
you're done analyzing the data set is
put everything in a repository on github
including code data and a readme file so
that the people who stumble upon your
repository you can see what you did and
this does say a lot
i highly recommend that you also write a
blog post about your analysis due to
several reasons first the world deserves
to know what you learn
as well
second when you start writing you
realize some parts of the story are
missing so it will help you wrap up
things and really complete the story and
do what i mentioned before like complete
the numbers with qualitative facts and
texts and this really
completes the thing
brings it like a level higher
and third reason is that
writing lifts up your understanding of
an issue sometimes in several events so
there's of the favor of going the one
extra mile and um
write a blog post
and after the blog post is done and
published i suggest you also present
your analysis in a meetup or a
conference so that it will be documented
and available on youtube as well
so
that's pretty much all the tips i
prepared for us today the last tip is
ask me questions
so if there are any
and just one comment super interesting
by the way uh mira thanks so much for
that
uh i i totally agree that writing about
your findings can really
help to
frame the the analysis in so many
different ways and and forces you to be
really communicative and then conscious
of your
communications
i like what you said also about uh
sharing the results of of our findings
and our analyses um
unfortunately it's not always possible
um depending on the data sources and the
client but
uh yeah certainly in these independent
analyses it's possible and that uh un
and world bank uh data repository have
some really great
data sets on there
okay sorry there's two q and a's here uh
so one thing so cody's saying one thing
i struggle with is communicating results
concisely to a business audience any
tips on balancing clarity and
conciseness
um
cody do you have an example
for the data you're dealing with the
news you have to explain it through
probably uh it's you know like
executive level people uh c-suite
don't have a lot of time and you need to
get this stuff across really quickly
so i suggest to first of all choose
plots that tell the story immediately
if you can and also i suggest
like i'm not sure if this related to the
question but in my opinion i think that
um
you should
you should not assume that they are
aware of data science
terminology
so i think you should
adjust
your vocabulary to people who are not
from this field
and not assume knowledge like explain
things basically when you say them
um another example another idea is i
think
i i think a good
presentation is when you take your
audience hand in hand from
not knowing anything about the topic to
the idea you're trying to bring so i
think you should try
using this approach i hope this is
helping
a question from jeremy the python
packages used to make these plots i
believe you said matplotlib seaborn and
networkx
uh sure so i used mostly sibol and
metplotlib
as i said before i really did dig into
the documentation and i looked into
different ways of plotting so this was
kind of a drawing class exercise at
times so i do recommend digging into
this and
then you have a ready code if you need a
new figure later
and there was a question before in the
chat
uh so i
put the links to my talk to my medium
and linkedin and everything
here i hope you see it
uh another question in the chat from joe
what do you do with large data sets
github is not a good place to store
this data yes very true
i have no idea because i took small ones
but
maybe zip or put a link to some place
they are in like
if you took it from some you probably
took it from somewhere online so you
could put the link to where it is
um i think when you read me
yeah go get your own server
uh question question from eli how do you
balance time and need for exploratory
analysis with stakeholders who are very
interested in results right away and how
do you emphasize that these results are
in fact exploratory rather than
precise and actionable results yeah good
point
so
yeah i'd say exploratory data analysis
at work is a tough issue i could do a
talk only on this um
for the type of fun i described here you
should probably do your own
projects
and if you need stakeholders or very
interested in results right away then
give it to them like don't do what i
suggested and then make it a playground
but do like
reach the point and
just give them what they want
sorry everybody's true
yeah i think that's a perennial
challenge is uh articulating the value
in this type of analyses
or the
at the exploratory phase rather than you
know producing direct results for for
clients and
and
bosses
yeah but you could also uh
eli i don't know um
you could also do um exploratory
analysis on the day that you work on
um as a side project for yourself and if
you found something interesting then
share it with your supervisor or
stakeholders or whatever and they would
probably appreciate it and if you don't
then at least you learned something
about you know coding visualizing
whatever so
don't
hesitate doing it or so on the data even
if you're not asked to at work
i think
thank you very much
thank you for having me